and on the fronts the
Supreme Commander-in-Chief
[applause]
and where he works
So exactly
this time is relevant and the people
who go to this course after
completing them feel more
secure today they will begin to
practically carry out shooting at the
firing lines will already try who
did not deal with weapons  those who have already trained
before will remember, that is
, the fighting style will be practically carried out
.
Why did they decide now to
participate in these exercises? If there is an
opportunity to study, you never know what
will be ready.
I live without a husband with my mother and son.
I have to protect my family
now the fire switch in the lower
position
in order to take the load off your
eardrums
all actions on my command